what up guys since you guys like the
last clothing haul that I did so much I
decided to do another one and because
this is such a rare occasion I know this
lady behind me does it all the time I
brought in an audience member because
ultimately who am I trying to impress
yourself no my mama bear
and uh the goal of all these hauls I've
been doing you want me to rip off my
clothes is that the cool no the actual
goal is
um
before what I noticed about myself is
I'll have a bunch of like super dope
clothes and then I have my like
athleisure like workout regular clothes
and because there's such a huge
difference I end up just resorting to
here so my day-to-day living looks just
bummy all the time because everything
else was like so up here so I was like
you know what I need to be realistic and
buy a lot of my normal daily driver
clothes so everything that I've been
buying is in that direction daily driver
but still swaggy
um not materials I have like dry clean
like crazy or not shoes that I'm scared
to scuff so here it is are you ready
I hope so all right a lot of these
things I've been collecting over time
because packages keep coming in
um so some of them might have some dust
on it so just uh bear with me
all right first thing is Bam these are
some cargo sweats that I thought would
be sick sweats by by Carhartt yeah
because for me you know like I'm like a
very short cargo pants what cargo sweats
like I know I know that sounds like
sweats they're sweats all right see it's
fleece what's cause I'm gonna be wearing
like sweats or Tech pants anyways so I'm
like how can I STEEZ that up like I'm
telling you I'm trying to be realistic
yeah
so what do you think okay
see sweatpants but it got a little bit
swag on it because of the pockets by the
bottoms could be depending on what kind
of shoes are rocking I'm saying got it
like
I just got these bad boys just laying
around because that's how swaggy I am
now
so I could pop these on right here real
quick
bam you know it's like ta
or I can tie it
it is pretty cool that their cargo
sweats right tight like right here
something like that yeah ankles just a
different look now
what do you think no they're good yeah
yeah I just wish you weren't such a
clown what do you mean I'm not a clown
no that's that's the that's the swag
that's the swag element all right I'm
talking about like that's what people
that's why I have to bite yourself so
you want to hear something funny what I
was I was in the background when you
were making the first haul yeah and you
busted out your Carhartt fleece sweater
yeah
and I was influenced look I was
influenced I influenced the influencer
so I didn't get the zip up one yeah I
got the what is this one called the
quarter yeah but that's how dope I am
where like my swag is wearing off the
swag that's really good and it's so soft
so I was watching the haul and I'm like
oh I need to get that and I got it
well don't bite me on this then look if
they're pants I'm biting it I got a
fleece
flannel have you ever seen a fleece
flannel
oh it's actually soft it's straight
up Felice player it's nice look at that
usually this material from what it looks
like yeah it's pretty rough but this
one's nice Carhartt boom and this is
specifically their whip line so make
sure you do Carhartt whip I even got
pockets look so you know it's meant to
be a jacket it's a real jacket
that would be really nice right yeah
it's really easy daily driver actually
wear it here yeah easy to maintain I
could wear it here
um it's not something where like
I'm scared to get like a stain on like
some of my super nice clothes I'm like
oh I don't want to like ruffle that or
crease that or I have to get that dry
cleaned so the maintenance makes it an
obstacle
both of these daily driver baby
shoes
I did get shoes but I'll get to that in
a bit
so as the weather gets a little bit
warmer I won't be able to be wearing the
super you know that's nice the thick
type of stuff that I have but
we do believe in layers so you don't
even try this stuff on like so I so you
already know you're gonna keep this yeah
because I don't try on my like
I'm literally trying it on and deciding
if I'm Gonna Keep it or not I'm a sniper
like I literally one shot one kill pop
so if I see it on the site I can
Envision on myself as long as it's not
too far away from what I've seen I'm
keeping it ow but if like the color's
way off or the photos are like weird or
like the fitment isn't as promised which
is why I like to go with Brands because
once
um you go with The Veranda okay this is
how it fits across the board okay that's
pretty so this is like a lighter jacket
button-up jacket see that
I like the uh well I like the
asymmetrical pockets
see how it's different oh so it brings a
little like a little Flair to it you
know what I'm saying so it doesn't look
like the typical like Dad type shirt
yeah where it's exactly the same it's
like a little little flare yeah and I
could layer this you know I mean like if
it's like super cold then like if I go
visit some homies
up in Canada
then I might be like have to put two of
them on you know what I mean like bam
look good like that Pam it's comfy wear
it on the plane but I'm really thinking
like all purpose like what is my
day-to-day yeah how much do I travel
I sit on in a chair at JK news I'm a hot
person
um
like I take I'm taking all of that into
consideration into this consideration
yeah as I purchase because I think
that's one of the biggest things that
prevented me
from wearing my nice clothes yeah is
those nice clothes have so much
maintenance yeah that it was like it's
just easier to just grab one of these
shirts or sweaters and just toss it in
the washer yeah
this one I'm really uh excited about
don't make me buy some more I don't
need
anymore so we got a little corduroy
jacket you know
and you love jackets well I guess you do
need I told you how much I love jackets
and why I didn't like living the legs I
couldn't wear none of my jackets yeah
and you had a ton in here but look at
this corduroy baby look at that that's
nice Bam put this on oh oh nice and warm
oh this is a good this is a good travel
one so I have another thick jacket like
this but then the it's canvas so it's a
little bit um stiffer and what I noticed
when I traveled recently is when you're
in the airplane seat it kind of crunches
you together because it's like a hard uh
fabric yeah this one is soft so you can
just sit in a bus sit on the airplane
nice and smooth yeah um what size are
you ordering large everything's large
everything's large baby I'm saying
that's large look
Mia has her clothes because she just got
uh neutered but looks good right yeah
got that
she's having a rough time over here and
my last scene from this package I kind
of forgot what this was actually
oh this is for extreme cold weather
it's uh because I was prepping for the
snowboard season
so I don't want to mess up my hair but
you put it in here and then you get your
eyes you can see your eyes yeah but then
I can cover my whole face for the
snowboard season
now
you're so cute
cute yeah I'll put on the whole I'll put
it yeah I'm like oh my God this would
look good with these shoes and I'm like
putting it together nah I'm piece by
piece I got it I got it we're different
what is this so I was really excited to
get this package because I thought this
was um I ordered some stuff from a
Japanese shooter company
I don't think this is it
ah no it's not more Carhartt stuff dang
it
dang it more Carhartt stuff oh I'm
excited about this jacket never mind
this one's dope
because this is for do you read the
material yeah oh yeah I read the
material but this one is without even uh
looking at it it's cotton it's popping
the material slightly water resistant I
just know like that's how into my eyes
are into stuff but I'm really excited
about this one because this one I saw
and I immediately fell in love because I
was like oh this is for sure one of
those daily drivers that can be slightly
elevated like some of the other stuff
you saw very casual right yeah um if I
want to roll up into one of the nicer
restaurants I might be like I'm kind of
underdressed this one I could already be
dressed in whatever pop this on and boom
the boss is here
while still being low-key
you know what I'm saying doesn't say a
raincoat yep it's cotton though so you
know it's not for the rain
you know so I could put like pop
looks clean you know what I'm saying if
I have some like boots some Red Wing
boots on bam like that you have some
yeah I do as a matter of fact
like that nice and loose it's a thinner
one
what do you think it's good it's good
right
I like it like that it's a little bigger
than I thought but if it's a large it's
a large so
I had two Japanese streetwear pants that
I was excited to get
I thought it was that package it's not
it's fine now I'll show you some of the
shoes I got
so some daily driver shoes it's got to
be dark colors because whites will
immediately get scuffed and it looks old
immediately I saw these um these are
ones I've never seen before this is a
Nike tactical shoe actually which I
thought was pretty cool
because it's just a it has like a harder
appearance and I felt like it can go
with a lot of things while because of
the materials isn't like crazy suede or
delicate I feel like it'd be like super
easy to clean
and if I wanted to go shooting
then go shooting in
what do you think
they're cool bam right yeah they look
very tactical they look like the
CrossFit like the Met cons a little bit
yeah yeah and I like it because like
anything from ACG is sick
oh
country gifts
so I am a big fan of duck boots I have a
green one that I got in Japan
so I feel like I'm wearing those out so
I just have to get them in brown those
are are sick you wear those in the snow
all the time right there and you've
always said how comfy they are oh you
can't see they're super comfy they're
like
they're like the function of a um
rain boot but the comfort of a
basketball shoe
then I got some of these New Balances
also Daily drivers see that
it's black it goes with anything it's
clean
those are nice
bam like that see those are real nice
it's clean right yeah they look great
with shoes they're gonna look like great
with your cargo sweats Grandma shoes
these are shoes uh shorts short socks so
these are dope because it's like of a
stealth look right
it's like like black but then just a
little bit of gray just to give it that
accent poop
and
last but not least
some daily driver
uh Air Max 97 so I'm a big fan of the
97s I had the uh I think these are
called the terrascapes I had the Air Max
90s unfortunately those things got beat
up because I traveled to them so much
um and I think the Air Max 90 has unless
you have a lot of shoes to switch with
one theme that is my personal Drive
about Air Max not even though a big fan
is they have a tendency to look worn in
real fast I have Air Max 97s the silver
ones that I've owned for like five years
and they still look brand new
so I got these ones in Black so that I
can rock them every day and still
look fresh so that's it for my travel
haul
um I'm at Travel Hall my fashion haul
um
if you like these I'll continue to buy
these uh but this I think was a good
amount of clothes to kind of revamp my
closet for a while so I don't get some
good base
yeah so I don't see myself getting
anything else
new for a few months because everything
on the other hand
every month every month expect one from
my bear
and if you like what I'm wearing
obviously my unders is always going to
be bottle Brigade all my tees and
hoodies and stuff like that so you can
see that at bumpergate.com thank you
guys for watching see you guys next time
bye